we do have a guest in studio now yes uh
a woman who has not had to back down in
this championship and she has won two of
them
and we can say
like cotter welcome back she doesn't
understand that reference she's too
young but nazi pakistani back in saint
louis nazi we we have to ask immediately
from the top
we thought you had retired and here you
are playing chess once again in st louis
uh thank you i'm very happy to be here
actually
i was retired but i think the pandemic
made me mischess
here i am you know chess has been
blessed by the pandemic in so many ways
and now we get blessed to have you
playing as well the hunger is back and
have you been training hard for this
tournament
yes i didn't have a lot of time of
course i had three months but last three
months i've been studying chess every
day yes
that's a lot of time for a lot of people
three months indeed you come right back
into this tournament and uh you get uh
old friend sabino foyza and you guys
were going at it she sacked a pawn on d5
at some point and uh did you feel like
it was proper sacrifice i actually
thought d fire was not a good sacrifice
i thought she played it because she
didn't like her position
but then i after we played i didn't
think i made any mistakes but somehow i
didn't get a good position so i figured
i guess d5 was okay
i think the engines were saying that it
was not and that you had you had like
maybe needed to play g4 in this position
or something which would have been a
very sharp
changing
consider that
but that felt like too much
that she already had compensation for
the pawn and by playing g4 i would be
giving her more compensation or yeah
loosening the position quite a bit well
a draw in the first round not a bad
result draw with white is not you
necessarily want but your aspirations
coming in you say you've been studying
chess every day for three months sounds
like you're trying to win your third
championship and of course everyone
comes here to win uh it's not a
tournament where you just play for
practice so um
yeah i didn't really get a better
position today so i'm not unhappy with
the draw
all right well i i do have a stat to ask
you i remember in your first two
championships you didn't lose in the
first championship
you had a great result you won the next
one
without a loss you also won another one
two championships later i believe also
without a loss that middle one how many
games did you lose i think uh overall
i've played four year championships and
i've only lost two games
wow okay that's a great result
all right well we look forward to seeing
you continue your final results welcome
back thank you very much absolutely
welcome back indeed this